HAASS: Well, good evening. Welcome to the
Council. I'm Richard Haass. And this is the
second installment in our new "What To Do
About" series. And tonight we're going to
be talking about what to do about Asia or,
more specifically, East Asia and the Pacific,
the part of the world that I believe more
than any other is likely to determine the
character of this century.
And there's lots of things we could focus
on tonight, but we are going to focus mainly
on the dynamics between China and Japan, in
many ways, the two most capable and important
local states, long-time not just neighbors,
but rivals. Tension has obviously been going
up, given the sovereignty dispute in the East
China Sea. Military capabilities are going
up. Military presence is going up. And nationalism
is going up.
You know, this competition or relationship
does not take place in a vacuum. There's lots
of other issues in the vicinity, including
Dennis Rodman's favorite subject, which is
North Korea, given other problems, say, in
the South China Sea, but tonight, we are largely
going to focus on them.
Now, what we're trying to do in this series
is really look at two issues. One is, what
can and should be done to prevent a crisis?
And then, secondly, if for whatever reason
or reasons prevention does not succeed, what
is then done to help manage a crisis? And
I guess we could be creative and say, if a
crisis were to happen, what could also be
done to take advantage of the crisis, not
just -- not just manage it?
And the way we're going to organize it is
essentially have a version of what you might
call a National Security Council meeting,
but rather than representing this or that
department, all three of these gentlemen I
will ask to simply be smart. And they are
particularly well-suited to be that, essentially,
to be ministers without portfolio or counselors,
but essentially wise men sitting around the
table offering their advice, so not representing
State or Defense or the intelligence community
or what have you, but simply being wise, experienced
hands, which -- it's exactly what they are.
Mike Green, who's sitting at the far end,
is at CSIS, where he's their senior vice president
for this part of the world. Also, he divides
his time with Georgetown University and in
days past was the senior director on the National
Security Council staff for this part, again,
of the world.
To his right, Jeff Bader, who has a similar
portfolio at the Brookings Institution, the
John Whitehead senior fellow there. And Jeff
was recently the senior director for East
Asian affairs on the NSC.
And last but least, Karl Eikenberry. Karl's
out at Stanford, so he's closer to Asia than
the other two these days. He was most recently
well-known as our ambassador to Afghanistan,
but what's particularly relevant for the purposes
of tonight's conversation, Karl was our defense
attache in Beijing and was the senior, what,
strategic adviser at PACOM?
EIKENBERRY: Strategic plans officer.
HAASS: Strategic plans officer at PACOM. So
what you have here is an extraordinary combination
of government experience both on the civilian
and military side and people now who are firmly
planted in the worlds of think-tanks and academia.
And, again, the question is, what to do about
Asia?
So let's start with the first part of it.
We'll talk for a bit. And then we'll open
it up and we'll get you out in plenty of time
to prepare for the State of the Union, which
I'm sure will be largely about this set of
questions.
(LAUGHTER)
So this will put you in a very good position
to impress your family and your neighbors
later this evening.
So let's just start with the question of prevention,
which is, how serious a challenge is this?
I mean, you wake up in the morning. There's
any array of domestic and international questions.
I was just recently at Davos. You had the
Japanese prime minister make reference to
events of 100 years ago. This is the 100th
anniversary of the outbreak of World War I,
and many people are drawing parallels between
the situation that existed in Europe prior
to the outbreak of World War I, great power
jockeying, a little bit of carelessness or
recklessness and so forth, rising nationalism.
We all know what that led to. Now we have
the situation in the Asia Pacific. How worried
should we be?
Why don't we start -- Karl, we'll just go
across.
EIKENBERRY: If we look back over the post-World
War II history of the Asia Pacific region,
it's an extraordinary success story. The economic
development that's occurred there, some 60
percent of the world's GDP now in the broader
Asia region. If you look at political success,
great success stories and democracy like Japan,
Korea, Taiwan, in through ASEAN, extraordinary
success there, as well. And the fact is that
today this is an area which is largely absent
hot conflict.
But yet to your question, though, Richard,
about how much should we be concerned, yes,
I think we should be very concerned, because
there are some trend lines that are not in
the right direction at present. For example,
last year marked the first year that in the
Asia Pacific region the combined defense budgets
are greater than Europe. That's the first
time in modern history that's occurred.
There's a set of territorial disputes that
exist in the Asia Pacific region that, if
not handled properly, could lead to military
conflict. There's the problem of on the Korean
peninsula. So we could go on from there, and
perhaps during the course of the discussion,
I know we'll want to talk about those specifics.
HAASS: Sure.
BADER: Well, I'll try to say something different
from Karl, though I agree with what Karl said.
I mean, basically, you know, we've all been
doing our speeches and articles on the Asia
Pacific since the Vietnam War, and they've
all been about this area as the success story
of the world. And I think if you were writing
-- if you were writing a national security
strategy right now on the region, you would
-- you would not be repeating that narrative.
Instead, you'd be talking about an area with
some storm clouds. You'd be talking about
an area with -- with some turmoil and some
conflicts or potential conflicts.
I mean, the Japan-China situation, if you
asked any of us 10 years ago, would we be
in this situation? None of us -- none of us
would have saw this. Thailand is up in smoke,
with seemingly no path to stability. The Japan-Korea
relationship is not going to be -- it's going
to be kinetic, but it's very, very bad. And
the China-Taiwan relationship is in decent
shape at the moment, but you have elections
in Taiwan in 2015, and who knows where the
relationship goes after that? And behind this
all, of course, you have a rising China with
a very -- how should we say -- forceful and
dynamic new leader, with a forceful and dynamic
foreign policy.
Just the last thing I'd say in the opening
here, Richard, is -- I mean, I talk to a lot
of Chinese and Japanese senior officials coming
through, and I don't know anyone who is itching
for a fight on either side. No one. That really
is not the question. The question is, what
happens when all these planes and ships circling
around each other if someone has one or two
-- two or three many scotches one evening?
HAASS: Michael?
GREEN: Well, on the proximate issue that you
introduced first, Richard, the Japan-China
problem, I would -- I would argue that the
possibility of a clash, of shots being fired
is significantly higher this year than it
was the year before, and was higher the last
year than it was the year before that, if
only because the amount of stuff in the East
China Sea and the rules of engagement are
somewhat dangerous.
The Japanese reported that they have scrambled
fighters to respond to Chinese fighters 80
percent more than they did the previous year.
The operational tempo for the white-hulled
coast guard ships is way up, and the gray-hulled
ships, although they're keeping a careful
distance, is way up. Polls in Japan and China
both show that 90 percent of the public doesn't
like each other.
Stepping back one level, does that mean that
there's going to be a war? I'd say extremely
low probability, even if there is an accident
or something like that, for all the reasons
Jeff said and because of our own power and
presence.
Stepping back one level further, do these
cracks and problems we see potentially represent
the beginning of disorder in Asia over the
longer term? Maybe. So we need to pay attention
to it to prevent the short-term crisis and
to make sure we're shaping the region for
a more stable future in the long run.
HAASS: Let me just push you on one thing,
and then we'll -- I'll turn to some just specific
policy questions. When you talk about it could
be the precursor of some disorder in Asia,
what does disorder in Asia look like?
GREEN: You have, as Jeff mentioned, the problems
of democracy in Thailand. You have states
in jeopardy. You have all the problems of
-- that other regions. But in the middle of
it, you have a rising China that, for the
most part, is not a revisionist power, that
wants to benefit from the international system,
despite frustrations with not having had a
role in creating it, but not trying to overturn
the prevailing order, which is an American-led
order.
If you -- what disorder looks like is that
the coercive element in Chinese diplomacy
today, arms -- excuse me, mercantile embargoes,
export embargoes to pressure countries on
territorial issues, course of use of ships
and planes, and diplomacy, it's one piece
of what China does, and one piece of a much
larger story, which has some good elements
and bad elements.
That becomes the dominant narrative for the
rest of the region, because of receding U.S.
power. That's a very dangerous situation.
That's what disorder looks like.
HAASS: OK, so let me ask, then, the basic
question. We want to influence Japan, so we've
got (inaudible) we've got an alliance relationship
there. So if the economists would call it
moral hazard, and it's the diplomatic counterpart
of it, how is it we're supportive of Japan,
so they don't feel they've got to do things
on their own, whether it's militarily or nuclear
or what have you, but without giving them
a blank check? How do we basically signal
American support that's -- that's considerable,
but not unconditional? Well, what is it we
say? What is it we do?
EIKENBERRY: Well, I think -- going back to
what Mike had said about making sure that,
first and foremost, our foundation for the
entire Asia Pacific region is engagement and
strength, and part of that is retooling our
economy and ensuring that we remain economically
relevant in the region, and that probably
is one of the biggest threats that the United
States is facing now.
Secondly, in terms then of our military posture
in the Asia Pacific region, to ensure that
we maintain the capabilities for base, that
we maintain strong alliances and partners
throughout the region, that also then gives
a context for the relationship with Japan.
HAASS: Well, let me just push you on that.
Does that entail increasing, for example,
the quality or quantity of our air and naval
presence?
EIKENBERRY: It does, yes. Japan's concerns
right now -- they have one concern with -- as
we all do -- with the Korean peninsula and
with North Korean threat, but I think their
deeper long-term concern is the rise of China
and the rise of China's military capabilities
behind that. And that's a concern that's reflected
throughout the Asia Pacific region.
And if we want to shape in a positive way
the development of China and to try to encourage
its further integration into regional architectures
and global architectures, then you do need
a position of strength to do that. And with
that strength then comes reassurance to our
allies.
HAASS: Let me ask a question, then, slightly
different, Jeff, which is, OK, if we should
maybe increase our military presence, which
largely means air and naval -- let's put aside
the question of Marines at Darwin. I never
quite understood how 2,000 Marines in the
Asia Pacific was going to tip the military
balance, but I'm sure that's my shortcoming.
The -- what about diplomatically doing more?
I mean, should we essentially -- we, the United
States -- insert ourselves in any way, I mean,
in this issue between Japan and China? Should
we have an American diplomatic initiative
about the legal political disposition of the
disputed islands? Or should we simply stand
back and let these guys try to sort it out?
I mean, is this a place where we ought to,
if you will, rebalance some of our diplomatic
activity towards this part of the world?
BADER: A few thoughts, Richard. And when I
was in the administration, we spent a lot
of effort on rebalancing our diplomatic presence
in Asia, particularly in Southeast Asia, but
I think we're not in Southeast Asia here now,
so I won't get into that, but there was a
lot of effort to do that.
Now, the Japan-China situation and then the
Japan-Korea situation, the administration
has put a lot of effort into quiet diplomacy
between the two. Joe Biden has been on the
phone with all -- you know, with the various
leaders. He's been out there. John Kerry,
as well. I would say the results have been
somewhere between minimal and negative, judging
by the trend lines. I say this not to be critical
of the individuals, but let's face it, these
are three (inaudible) Japan and South Korea,
who are, I would say, very friction-tolerant.
Each one, it's in their -- it's in the interest
of each one of them to have difficult relations
with the others. It's in their political domestic
interests, and that is something we cannot
(inaudible) dynamic, we cannot overcome that.
HAASS: Can I just interrupt you on one point,
just so I understand? So whatever level of
diplomatic activity we've been carrying has
had results that you describe between negligible,
I think it was, or modest, whatever it was,
and negative, would more diplomacy have a
positive result? Or does more diplomacy actually
risk having a larger negative?
BADER: I mean, I think -- you know, I was
being slightly facetious, but not entirely.
We have to be engaged privately with them.
We've certainly -- between the Japanese and
the Koreans, we certainly have to play a role,
since they can't seem to work it out themselves.
With the Japanese and the Chinese, clearly,
as you -- you know, you raised the issue of
moral hazard, the administration's been trying
to convey to the Japanese since the middle
of 2011, don't do anything reckless with the
islands. Kurt Campbell conveyed that message
before Noda...
(CROSSTALK)
HAASS: It's kind of what we used to tell Taiwan.
BADER: Hmm?
HAASS: It was kind of what we used to often
tell Taiwan, don't do anything reckless to
change the status quo.
BADER: And then they went ahead and did it.
I mean, look, as the great power in the region,
we have no choice. We have to be engaged.
The powers -- each of the powers actually
wants us engaged privately. None of them wants
us out there publicly taking sides, seeking
to embarrass, or putting forward formulas
for them to come to, like the, let's say,
Middle East peace...
HAASS: Well, it's worked so well there. We
thought we might transfer it to this part
of the world.
(LAUGHTER)
So then, what then is the nature of American
diplomatic engagement, if it's not to resolve
the questions of sovereignty? You know, I've
heard everything from, you know, creating
special types of environmental parks and,
you know, sort of whatever to -- I mean, is
there a substantive initiative, do we think?
Or is it simply, don't change the status quo
unilaterally by force? Is that the substance
of our diplomatic message?
GREEN: You're talking about the Japan-China
piece and the Senkaku-Diaoyu-type problem?
Look, for CFR or Brookings or CSIS, we ought
to dive into the deep end of that pool and
see what we can do in terms of intellectual
facilitation. For the U.S. government, Japan's
an ally, and we cannot be in a position of
brokering between an ally and a power that
is testing not only Japan on the Senkakus
and Diaoyu ties, but all along the first island
chain.
If you're worried about China grabbing the
islands or doing something provocative, you
want to hew close to Japan. If you read about
Japan doing something provocative, you want
to hew closely to Japan. We don't have a joint
and combined alliance with the Japanese the
way we do with NATO or with Korea. The Japanese
didn't want it. And for decades, it was the
Japanese that worried about being entrapped
in our war in Vietnam or in China and Korea.
And now, you know, for about the past decade,
we've started worrying a little bit about
maybe being entrapped in their war for the
first time.
The answer is to move towards more jointness,
more joint exercises, more concept of operations,
so that we're inside the Japanese decision-making
loops and we're making decisions together
and we're dissuading China. The worst thing
we could do is to step back and sort of leave
it to the Japanese to sort out or to somehow
broker, which would only encourage Japanese
hedging, which is unhelpful, and Chinese hopes
that perhaps there's a way to drive a wedge
between us.
HAASS: Karl, you spent time in Beijing as
the attache. What message do we give the Chinese
about restraint? And then, if they go, well,
hold it, does that mean under any and all
circumstances, well, no way? What is it tell
the Chinese in order to, again, behave responsibly,
if they say, but what if the Japanese do X,
Y and Z? Do you still expect us to show restraint,
even if the Japanese are not?
EIKENBERRY: Yeah, this is a -- look this is
a very difficult problem with regard to the
Senkaku and Diaoyu. And the consequences of
getting this wrong, or as Jeff had said, a
Japanese fighter pilot making a mistake and
a shooting match starting, almost certainly
not leading to a war, but really setting Asia
back and our own position in Asia back tremendously,
that it's rising with every day.
Last year, Mike talked about fighter sorties
from the Japanese air self-defense force over
the islands. Six hundred last year scrambled.
That's two a day. And it's a matter of time
until -- it's just a matter of time until
something happens.
Now, the tough part about this for us is that
we do have an alliance with Japan, and that
alliance specifically covers the Senkakus
and Diaoyu. And if, according to the treaty,
that if the Japanese are attacked in the Senkaku-Diaoyu,
then we have a treaty obligation there.
Now, we don't go to war based upon lawyers'
interpretations of treaties, of course. And
a point I would like to make about this is
that I remember as a colonel working in the
office of secretary of defense when some island
occurred -- dustup occurred in the Asia Pacific
region. I called an old State Department...
HAASS: It wasn't Kenmoya Matsu (ph), was it?
EIKENBERRY: It -- no, I'm a little bit -- a
little bit beyond that one.
(LAUGHTER)
HAASS: OK. Just checking.
EIKENBERRY: But I called up a very senior
retired diplomat, who I thought a lot of,
and asked for his opinion. He said, Karl,
remember the first rule here. The United States
of America is a great power and great powers
don't go to war over rocks. Having said that,
though, these are not just rocks to the Japanese
and the Chinese. We know how sensitive this
issue is.
Your point about -- then your question, what
do we tell the Chinese? Well, I think that
the Chinese are observing our diplomacy right
now, and clearly they see how we're engaging
with Tokyo, as we did in the aftermath that
Prime Minister Abe's visit to the Yasukuni
shrine. They are clearly getting messages
from us that we want to see Tokyo and Beijing
talking to each other about this.
Tokyo -- Beijing's position is that, as long
as Tokyo will admit there's a dispute here,
then we can sit down and talk, and Tokyo has
not found the way at this point to reach that
formula, but I'd be optimistic that they could
with some clever diplomacy.
HAASS: Let me ask two more questions on the
prevention side of the coin. The Chinese recently
-- must be, what, several months ago now -- announced
the air defense identification zone. Is there
anything we can or should do vis-a-vis that
that would basically send messages such as,
we believe, to decrease the chance of a crisis
or an incident, in terms of respecting it,
challenging it, what have you? What -- the
Chinese put that out here. It was, if you
will, a unilateral challenge to the status
quo. What should we be doing about it?
BADER: Well, the -- I mean, DOD responded
instantly, within 24 hours, by sending a B-52
over the area, which I think was absolutely
the right -- the right signal. I mean, I think
it was -- you know, there are two issues,
military aircraft and civilian aircraft, and
we got somewhat crosswise in our messaging
on that. The military...
HAASS: Can you just explain where we came
out on that?
BADER: Yeah, where we came out was -- DOD
was very clear, this was not going to affect
in any fashion military aircraft operations
inside the ADIZ, no notification, they would
continue as before, which is absolutely the
right call. We have a lot of -- you know,
a lot of operations in that zone, and we're
not about to announce them to the Chinese
or ask permission. We have no obligation under
international law, international practices
to do so.
On the civilian side, I mean, both Hagel and
Kerry made clear statements that the way our
ADIZ works is you only have a reporting requirement
if you are flying towards the country, towards
the United States. If you're just transiting
the zone, no reporting obligation whatsoever.
And the Chinese announcement makes no such
distinction, so a plane -- you know, an ANA
flight from Tokyo down to Singapore that cuts
through the zone nominally has to report or
the Chinese can scramble something to see
what's going on, which is not a healthy situation.
I think that the FAA put out a general guidance
saying, we respect ADIZs and we expect civilian
aircraft to honor them, OK? That wasn't very
well coordinated within the U.S. government,
frankly. It send confusing signals. The Japanese
didn't know quite what to make of it.
HAASS: Should we amend it, now?
BADER: Should we have...
HAASS: Should we now amend it?
BADER: I mean, the FAA's view was, we don't
use our civilian aircraft as experiments or,
you know, that they're -- we don't put civilians
at risk because of diplomatic purposes. And
I understood what the FAA was doing. It was
the -- I'm not sure, Richard. I don't know
the answer to that. It was just badly coordinated.
I don't know if I'd go beyond that.
EIKENBERRY: On my last United flight to Beijing,
I actually supported the FAA position.
(LAUGHTER)
BADER: That's the point. I mean, you know,
those of us who did KOL-7 (ph) 30 years ago...
HAASS: Exactly. I remember that.
BADER: But I think the important thing to
warn China is, don't do this again in the
South China Sea or in the Yellow Sea. I think
that's the great risk, that they'll -- particularly
in the South China Sea, where you've got a
whole bunch of claimants, not just one claimant,
and that would really be -- I think that would
really be a provocation if they would do that.
HAASS: I guess this is the last question,
and I'll start with Mike, which is, diplomatically,
in the interests of preventing a crisis or
conceivably better managing one, if it were
to happen all the same, why not make a big
push for introducing a set of confidence-building
measures in this part of the world, incidents
at sea, various types of communications, or
even some version of the Conference on Security
and Cooperation in Europe, some type of a
more structured security system for this part
of the world, which have certain rules of
the road, certain obligations, certain mechanisms
for stabilizing.
This part of the world is drowning, literally
and figuratively, in economic arrangements
and, in many ways, is extraordinarily thin
in diplomatic and in political-military arrangements.
So why not now the -- why wouldn't we as a
government -- and to the extent we represent
the United States government here -- why wouldn't
we take this initiative to introduce essentially
a set of proposals to help regulate, if you
will, or increase the structure of the Asia
Pacific in a political-military sense? Why
not do that?
GREEN: We should. There is more happening
just in the last year or two on that front
than those of us who watch the region have
seen in decades. The ADMM-Plus, which is a
Southeast Asian-based defense cooperation
summit, is now holding regular multilateral
exercises almost on a monthly basis, and that's
-- that's long overdue.
The U.S. has been urging China since Karl
was a colonel in the Pentagon, working on
China, to implement a piece of paper we signed
on maritime military transparency and confidence-building.
And the Japanese would like something like
that, and the Chinese won't even talk to them
about it.
So we should be doing that. I think the PLA
-- and Karl knows this well -- have a different
view of transparency and what it means. They
would like, as a matter of principle for us,
to stop doing surveillance, to stop doing
things we've been doing for 60 years in the
region. If we can agree on some of those principles,
they'll talk to us about transparency.
So we'll make some progress in multilateral
exercises. We'll have frustration with confidence-building.
But that should be a central part of our effort.
And if I could real quick, the -- the Chinese,
as Karl said, want Japan to acknowledge de
jure, not just de facto, that there's a dispute.
I think the Japanese could do that, but they
can't do it under coercion, and we shouldn't
want them to do it under coercion.
So this is an area where the U.S. could have
a role. It's not brokering, but with clear
signals and organizing our friends and allies
in the region and partners, make it clear
to Beijing they're not going to get any progress
and we're going to hold them accountable,
as long as they resort to coercion to try
to undermine Japan's claim to administrative
control of those islands.
But if there's some basis to remove that coercive
tool, there might then be a basis for Japan
and China to have some -- I mean, the game
would be Japan would call on China to go to
the international court, knowing the Chinese
wouldn't go, but they will have made -- so
there is room for us to play, but it can't
be ecumenical in the sense we need to recognize
that the Chinese coercion is a major problem
for all of us in this.
HAASS: OK, so let's -- let's do something
the U.S. government is not terribly good at,
which is contingency planning. And so let's
assume that at some point either some fighter
pilot on one or another side will -- his testosterone
will get out of control and he will do something
quite aggressive, or some ship captain will
have too much to drink and he will do something
quite dumb, and there's an incident, and there's
a collision of aircraft, ships, whatever.
What do we do? What is it we immediately do?
Because one of the things that's not obvious
to me is the locals. They don't have dedicated
communications links. They don't have a large
amount of experience in managing crises. So
what is it the United States does, if you
will, to keep an incident just an incident,
rather than the seed of escalation?
EIKENBERRY: You want to start with that one?
BADER: I'll start on that. We do have crisis
communication links, the U.S. and China.
HAASS: The U.S. -- yeah...
(CROSSTALK)
BADER: We have, you know, I think CNO with
his -- the chief of naval operations with
his counterpart, president has a secure link
with Xi Jinping. We've used them. And presumably,
those would be activated right away. The Japanese
and Chinese actually do have some links, but
they just haven't utilized them -- utilized
them much.
You know, in 2010, when a drunken Chinese
sea captain bumped a Japanese coast guard
vessel, a few of us were out there immediately
talking about Article V and mutual security
treaty, to try to send the clear signal to
the Chinese that this -- that this had consequences.
And, you know, what we've tried to communicate
to the Japanese is, the alliance is firm and
seamless, but please don't make rocks the
centerpiece of the alliance.
You know, what you do in a crisis, I think,
you know, this is really Karl's world, but
I -- I mean, I have no doubt there would be
movements orchestrated from your coast guard
and from the region to have some presence.
But I think the assumption has been that the
Japanese are reasonably capable of taking
care of themselves in a small-scale incident,
and the U.S. doesn't have to come and shouldn't
come charging in, which would, you know, escalate...
(CROSSTALK)
HAASS: But do we move U.S. air and naval assets?
I mean, quite honestly, if there is an incident
-- and say there's some scrambling of Japanese
or Chinese aircraft, there's some movement
of vessels, what do we do? And do we physically
in any way try to interpose ourselves? Do
we hold back? What's our role in this?
EIKENBERRY: Well, in terms of Japanese capabilities,
military capabilities, should there be an
incident around the Senkaku-Diaoyu, then initially
the Japanese do have the capabilities to take
care of themselves, so to speak.
The United States really wouldn't have to
move forces, Richard, into the area. In fact,
that could be -- depending upon how the situation
evolved, that could be very counterproductive,
because the Chinese could be interpreting
this, then, as a reinforcement of the Japanese.
And until we understood better what Beijing's
intents were, I think that that could be very
escalatory.
On the other hand, we have a remarkable set
of capabilities that are over the horizon
up in space that we can be very useful to
the Japanese military, in terms of helping
them understand, get situational awareness.
I'd go a step further. If we'd -- if we were
to be sending signals, which we would immediately
about trying to de-escalate rapidly and trying
to get the Japanese and the Chinese to both
be saying from Beijing and Tokyo that they
wanted to de-escalate this, that we could
also play perhaps a role in terms of providing
transparency to all sides that would be reassuring
that might help them to have the confidence
to go forward diplomatically than -- and to
begin to talk.
GREEN: I may be the outlier, but -- and it
depends a lot on how this happened. You know,
did the Japanese provoke by putting a lighthouse
up? Did the Chinese, you know, land? I mean,
a lot of it depends on how this happened.
But with that as a caveat, if this was -- if
this involves -- if it looks like the Scarborough
Shoal incident...
HAASS: Explain what that is.
GREEN: So what happened in Scarborough Shoal
between the Philippines and China was, the
Philippines and China both claimed the waters.
The Philippines have been fishing it for a
millennium. The U.S. tried to broker in that
case an agreement for the forces to stand
off. The Chinese side came in anyway. The
Philippines Navy took one of these old Coast
Guard cutters we gave them and went steaming
with flags flying and drums and bugles playing
right out into this horseshoe-shaped atoll,
and the Chinese cut them off. They didn't
have food and water, and they basically pulled
out, and they haven't operated there since.
The Chinese now have effective operational
control.
If that happened with this East China Sea
against Japan, the strategic implications
for us across the region, in terms of how
others view our staying power, the credibility
of our security commitments, and how China
views them, could be really devastating. So
we'd have to take that into consideration.
It doesn't mean we move forces. Probably we
don't move forces into the immediate area,
because my guess is, the Japanese will pull
back.
But if we're going to ask the Japanese to
stand down, we're going to have to do something.
And I think, if this were a simulated NSC,
there would be very serious consideration
about flexible deterrent options, as they're
called, B2s (ph), and so forth, moving to
Guam. Not a lot of press necessarily, but
there's going to have to be a little bit of
muscle, not in the middle of the fight, maybe
from space, maybe other assets, and declaratory
policy that is just enough to let the Japanese
feel confident and the rest of the region
feel confident, but not so much that we provoke
escalation. That's a tough call. That's why
it depends on exactly how it unfolds.
HAASS: But isn't, then, the most complicated
scenario one in which the Japanese seem to
be the ones who have initiated it? It's one
thing, if the Chinese do certain things, then
it's almost more straightforward. But it seems
to me by far the most complicated policy for
-- scenario for the United States is one in
which the Japanese, quote, unquote, "seem
to be at fault."
GREEN: Are you looking at me?
HAASS: I'll look at...
GREEN: As the Japan guy?
HAASS: Yeah.
GREEN: And then I started studying Korean
again. No, I think then you get to the prevention
problem. That's why I mentioned earlier, we
need to be inside the planning loop. And...
(CROSSTALK)
HAASS: OK. This assumes -- we assume that
we missed that opportunity, for whatever reason.
GREEN: Then we have a problem. But then what
we -- we start to create it quickly, and we
start talking about scenario planning, contingency
planning. The other thing that I think...
HAASS: That's what we're talking about now.
Mike, basically...
GREEN: No, I mean -- I mean, in the crisis.
That's what you have to do.
HAASS: Yeah. Yeah.
GREEN: The other thing I think that's important
is to -- this is not the right choice of words,
in a way, but regionalize the problem. In
other words, you could see with Prime Minister
Abe that part of Japan's playbook to deal
with a rising China is to strengthen ties
with Australia, India, Philippines. Korea
would be nice, but it's not happening.
I think in these kinds of crises, we want
our Australian friends, other actors to weigh
in and to echo the messages of reassurance
and restraint. And that kind of external solidarity
will help and also send a signal to Beijing
that the region has a stake in how this plays.
BADER: Richard, if I could just add a word,
I think that the basic formula would be to
have highly visible support for Japan combined
with extremely strong messaging behind the
scenes to them, not to interpret this visible
support as anything resembling a blank check
or a green light.
I mean, I went through something like this
in late 2010 with North and South Korea, after
the North Koreans shelled the South Korean
islands. And we had to face two questions.
One is, do we support the South Koreans in
a follow-up exercise? And we had a big debate
about it and -- most of us, and the consensus
was, yes, we had to, and be visible, and we
had a carrier in the region. But we also at
the same time stuck, you know, put Mike Mullen
on a plane to go out there and tell them,
you can -- don't you do any of the things
that you are threatening to do that would
escalate the situation. So there was a big
difference between the public and the private
messaging.
HAASS: Let me use the Middle East again as
an analogy, in this case where a crisis did
lead to extremely productive diplomacy, which
was the '73 war. And you had certain things,
and out of that, Henry Kissinger was able
to do the disengagement agreements and ultimately
it set in motion what years later became also
an Egyptian-Israeli rapprochement.
Is there anything about a crisis in this part
of the world that we can run with it, not
that we want one to happen, but if you've
got lemons, make lemonade? Is there any lemonade
to be made here?
EIKENBERRY: I don't know, Richard. In the
case of the Korean peninsula, I could see
a path ahead where if there was to be a -- if
there were to be an act of war, that perhaps
where we are with China right now and the
Republic of Korea, there could be opportunity,
but in this instance, where we're talking
about the East China Sea or the South China
Sea, I don't see very clearly where the opportunity
would be. I think for now, as I see it, avoidance
is critical here.
HAASS: Jeff?
BADER: The dispute between China and Japan
is not about the Senkakus. The Senkakus is
an excuse. I mean, from the Chinese perspective,
I think there are three things, number one,
is a visceral, gut resentment of Japan for
its historic role vis-a-vis China in the last
century. Number two is a tactical desire to
use -- to paint Japan as reverting to the
1930s, because they're trying to slow down
Abe's building up of the security capabilities.
So it's gut, and it's also highly calculated.
And the third piece of it is just terror on
the part of the Chinese leaders of being -- of
appearing to be soft on Japan, because of
the impact that that might have on their leadership.
HAASS: So then why wouldn't the answer to
your -- if there were a crisis -- I agree
with you. So the answer's not to necessarily
to -- I wouldn't be against it -- negotiating
some new legal or whatever -- political, legal
framework for the islands, but that would
be the time to basically say, this is a relationship
that needs managing. And what we really want
to do is put in a much thicker web of ties,
whether it's to prevent crises or deal with
crises, whether it's bilateral or regional,
but that seems to me -- if a crisis scared
people about what could happen, and stock
markets around the region plummeted, there
is an argument -- at least that would be the
time to do some things that now might be resented,
but in those conditions, there might actually
be a greater opening.
GREEN: You might get that effect for a while,
clearly, if the U.S. played its role rightly.
There's a loss of face. If we -- together
with Japan -- somehow force China to back
down, that has very dangerous implications
for us domestically, to a lesser extent, but
still also true in Japan.
If we play it right, we might -- especially
if the stock markets crash and the economic
players come in -- we might start to get a
sort of -- a more stable situation, but it'll
be like the 1995-'96 Taiwan Straits crisis,
where the militaries were so calculating where
their vulnerabilities were, where our vulnerabilities
are, and how they build up their force posture
over the next decade so they can win next
time.
So there's almost -- I hate to sound so pessimistic
-- there's almost no way we come out of this
with a happy, you know, recognition of how
dangerous things were. You know, I -- it's
-- I don't see the Cuban missile crisis, you
know, scenario necessarily. There's going
to be learning. Some of it will be good; some
of it will be how to hedge better and prepare
better for the future.
EIKENBERRY: I think also that we need to look
at Senkaku-Diaoyu in terms of broader Chinese
policies now in the East China Sea, the South
China Sea. Over the last three decades, China's
been remarkably successful, with the exception
of India, of finalizing and getting international
recognition for its land borders, but it has
not on the maritime front, and I think that's
where it's turning to right now, and it has
growing interest. It has growing capabilities.
And I think it's useful for an audience like
this to think about American history and recall
in 1823, when President Monroe declares the
Monroe Doctrine, and a Monroe Doctrine is
declared at a point where America started
to define its interests as no European interference
in the Western Hemisphere.
Now, if you go back to China, from the mid-1990s
until today, you look at their behavior in
the maritime domain, and is there -- without
anybody in Beijing having a Xi Jinping doctrine
locked up in the safe -- but just is there
an evolution of their thinking based upon
capabilities and interests that they're reaching
a point where they -- they don't want U.S.
reconnaissance activities 12 nautical miles
off of their coast. They have a different
view of the Senkaku and Diaoyu. They have
a different view of the Spratly Islands.
So I think it's going to be very difficult
for us to manage these problems as they come
up. You talked about the Philippines case.
Now we're talking about Senkaku-Diaoyu. But
we also have to bear in mind, in terms of
the United States, our way of operating militarily
in the Western Pacific since the end of the
Second World War was that was an American
lake. And I think the Chinese are reaching
a point where they have a different interpretation
of this.
That's not an argument for us to pull back
on any of our commitments, but we have to
be clear among ourselves in these kind of
discussions that that's -- that's the trajectory
China is on, and that's going to be part of
the equation here.
GREEN: There is a doctrine, by the way. It
was called the Near Sea Doctrine. It's evolved.
I was actually briefed on it at the Academy
of Military Sciences a few years ago, Central
Military Commission approved it. Not unlike
the Monroe Doctrine, the ends, ways and means
don't match. It's more aspirational. But that's
the trend. I think it's pretty clear, yeah.
HAASS: Right. Well, on that note, let's open
it up. Anything is fair game, either about
the Chinese-Japanese relationship, or we can
broaden it out to other potential scenarios.
Winston? Ambassador Lord, excuse me?
QUESTION: Just call me Your Excellency, any
of those things will work.
(LAUGHTER)
Win Lord, International Rescue Committee.
It's good to see some old friends here. First,
one quick comment. When Jeff was discussing
what we did in 2010, it reminded me of the
Taiwan missile crisis, where we -- clearly,
China was the provocative party there, but
we moved two aircraft carriers, but at the
same time, we sent strong message to Taiwan
not to treat it as a blank check and to China
that we weren't changing our one China policy.
So there are echoes there.
But my question to any of you is the following,
and you touched on it a little bit. What are
the chances the following would work, that
the -- and maybe it's happening -- I seriously
doubt it, given the atmospherics -- that China
and Japan have secret talks, Japan comes up
with some formula of great ambiguity, a la
Shanghai communique, whatever it was, the
'92 consensus with Taiwan, which basically
says -- I don't have the language, but our
Chinese friends think there's a dispute over
these islands. We don't think there's a dispute
over these islands, so obviously we disagree.
China takes that as saying Japan agrees there's
a dispute. Abe tells his people, I didn't
change our position, but it's enough, but
that is only done by the Japanese in exchange
for prior Chinese assurance they would then
de facto start cutting down on their patrols
and their probes and de facto making a more
peaceful situation.
Could this work? And is anybody trying it?
BADER: I'll take the first shot. Winston,
it's completely logical. Therefore...
HAASS: So it had no chance whatsoever?
(LAUGHTER)
BADER: I mean, I -- I had this discussion
with Japanese friends like a year ago, word
for word. And the answer was -- I mean, there
were two problems, number one, that Abe wouldn't
do it, no matter how artful the language was,
and, number two, what was the expectation
of how far back the Chinese would go. In conversations
I had with Japanese visitors close to Abe,
I -- you know, I told them, I thought the
best you're going to -- you're not going to
get status quo ante. The Chinese are going
to continue to send a ship inside those territorial
waters. Just they won't do it every week or
two. They might do it once per six months
or once a year. They're going to feel the
need to continue to establish the principle
that they have of presence there.
And the answer I got from this gentleman close
to Abe was status quo ante is the only thing
that is of the slightest interest to us. Now,
I have no idea if this was an official position,
but those were the kind of feelers I got.
Now where we are now, in the wake of Yasukuni,
is that almost any conversation is next to
impossible for, say, some months.
GREEN: Yeah, I think in the near term, it's
impossible. But there are people in the Japanese
foreign ministry, I think, who are thinking
along those lines and in the Chinese foreign
ministry. The problem is that it will help
to lower the temperature, but the problem
ultimately will be that China's move is very
reversible.
And it reminds me of something that was proposed
to us when I was in the White House by the
foreign ministry, if we stopped Taiwan arms
sales, China would pull back its missiles.
Some people thought that was a great deal,
until they started doing the math and realizing
our stopping Taiwan arms sales is much harder
to reverse than a quiet, you know, return
of some mobile missiles in Fujian.
So the foreign ministry in China tries these
things. They had an agreement with the Japanese
on joint oil exploration, for example. But
as you know very well, Win, the foreign ministry
has a very hard time actually implementing
these.
So for this to happen, it's going to have
to come out of Xi Jinping and the new national
security council, or whatever they're translating
it as, and for the reason Jeff said, the temperature
is just all wrong right now. But in the next
three years, I wouldn't entirely rule it out.
It just doesn't solve the problem. All it
does is lower the temperature.
EIKENBERRY: Yeah, the -- I think the key right
now is to find a way as rapidly as possible,
if there is a way ahead, to demilitarize this
dispute, because it's extraordinarily dangerous.
I don't know -- and, you know, my recent trips
to Beijing, I'm not certain at this juncture,
though, Win, whether the Chinese leadership
is, as they've said, given up on Abe. Well,
you can say you've given up on him and then
things can change next week and they'll talk
to him again.
But I do think we're at a point where it's
going to require the very highest levels of
leadership, Abe and Xi, to set the tone, give
the signals for the two sides to sit down
in a serious way behind closed doors, which
you're talking about, and I think there could
be formulas there. I think that one of the
outcomes of that, though, would be a better
outcome if there was also some kind of crises
management mechanism established to where
the combined militaries and law enforcement
agencies were talking to each other on a daily
basis, as I agree with you, Mike, that they'll
-- the Chinese will come back and they'll
say, domestically, politically, they have
to keep on trying to find ways to say that
they're asserting their administrative control
of Diaoyu, and with that, then, to have that
crisis management mechanism established and
agreed transparency between the two sides
I think would be awfully important to try
to sustain the agreement.
HAASS: Yes, sir?
QUESTION: Hi, Dan Rosen. Nice to see everybody.
There seems to be a consensus that the domestic
utility of this conflict is one of the major
drivers here, that this is for domestic consumption
on both sides. On the Chinese side, what's
going on right now that's so different than
a year ago that justifies, in terms of domestic
utility, this level of tension? Because there's
some Chinese optionality and choice in how
high to turn the dial here, I would guess.
It's not just a reaction to Japan. It's a
choice on Beijing's side.
So what is it in the political economy in
Beijing right now that makes this reasonable
from a domestic, political perspective?
BADER: Well, let me take an opening shot,
Dan. I would not answer the question directly.
I mean, what I would say is that I think the
reason why China's tone has changed so dramatically
in the last two years is because of Abe and
because of the perception of the security
policies that Abe is pursuing. And the desire
to depict Abe as a throwback to the 1930s
to try to rally Northeast and Southeast Asian
regional opinion against him as a way of sort
of putting some spokes -- some brakes on his
intended direction on security policy. I think
that's fundamentally what is underlying the
volume coming out of Beijing now.
HAASS: You don't think it has to do, also,
with the slowdown of economic growth, a new
leadership trying to establish itself, cutting
a closer relationship with the military, trying
to harness nationalism for its own domestic
political purposes?
EIKENBERRY: My own view would be, yes, that's
a factor, and it certainly is. And I think,
though, the Chinese leaders collectively,
you know, led by Xi right now are also aware
that they're facing an extraordinary array
right now of domestic problems. They're trying
to restructure their economy, which has got
huge political consequences. They're facing
an environment which is so polluted that they're
worried about grassroots movements starting
to form and network within China against the
party's leadership. We all know what this
array of problems is.
And what that leads to, then, is the conclusion
of the third plenum of the 18th Party Congress
that what they need for the next decade is
they need stability. They need stability in
China, and they can only maintain stability
in China if they have a region that's stable
and global security situation which is generally
favorable.
So they're not in a real maverick mood right
now. They also are very aware of second- and
third-order consequences. When they try to
play the nationalist card, if they do, they
have a history of playing that card, and then
the Japanese -- the anti-Japanese protests
suddenly take on an anti-party tone to them.
But all of that said, I would agree, Richard,
that Xi Jinping taking over -- and he's very
activist. In every area, you hear -- we used
to hear about Hu and Wen, now you only hear
about Xi. And that's in domestic politics.
That's in terms of security policies and foreign
policies, and perhaps part of it trying to
be a strong commander-in-chief and get the
People's Liberation Army lined up behind him.
HAASS: Just out of curiosity, where does the
establishment or the declaration of the new
air defense zone, what's your interpretation
of that? Is that an exception to this? Is
this part of it? I mean, did the Chinese miscalculate?
What's your...
GREEN: I think this is part of a playbook
that was established under this maritime doctrine,
with ADIZs somewhere in our future in the
West Sea or...
HAASS: Please explain -- don't -- you can't
use that -- you can't say ADIZs. No one knows
what you're talking about.
GREEN: Sorry, air defense identification zone,
which is a mouthful. Can I say ADIZ now? Because
there's going to be another one in Yellow
or West Sea, west coast of Korea, and in the
South China Sea. And this is salami slicing.
I'm told -- and Jeff or Karl may know better
-- that the leadership actually expected Vice
President Biden to cancel his trip over this
and that the U.S. response – though still
quite firm on the military side, and I think
if they felt that they misread our politics,
our foreign policy, but that the U.S. response
was perhaps less than they expected.
So I think this is -- this is not a one-off.
I think step by step, we're going to see more
and more of these things. And we'll just have
to take them as they come, but we have to
put it in part of a larger strategic construct
we don't quite have yet.
HAASS: Roger?
QUESTION: (OFF-MIKE) Capital. The tone, of
course, in Washington, when I got there four
years ago, was that they got a lot of economics
at stake and they won't do anything to put
that at risk. So I think that National Security
Council meeting that you're convening here
today, Richard, would have a lot on the economic
aspects of it, particularly what kind of economic
carrots and sticks can be brought to the table.
And you have to realize the Chinese have numerous
grievances against us, and then generally,
on many things, but it -- the bullying started
with the rare earth embargo in 2010. And the
first grievances that we actually went forward
a WTO case against China, on the case of rare
earth, of market manipulation, and that's
still ongoing.
But they have grievances on investment. They're
very active in going to the Financial Times
and other newspapers complaining that they're
not treated fairly by the Committee on Foreign
Investment in the United States, CFIUS. They
have grievances that they -- that we goaded
them for support -- financial support for
countries in trouble at the IMF and the World
Bank, but they don't get the quid pro quo
of American support for them having greater
influence on decision-making. And they think
that TPP, the Trans-Pacific Partnership negotiations,
is -- one, the economic side of the pivot,
namely, a containment policy against China,
and they say they don't want to be contained.
So each one of those grievances gives an opportunity
and a risk. The opportunity is, meet some
of their objections. Open things up. Sell
them more military high-tech products, which
is in every speech that all of the Chinese
leaders always say. You think that trade is
about foreign exchange rates; we think it's
because of the stuff that you won't sell us.
On the other hand, we need the Chinese on
things like Iranian sanctions enforcement.
And so we are in a much more complex economic
and financial situation with China than any
adversary you can dredge up from the Cold
War. We didn't have any of these kinds of
links with the Russians.
HAASS: Let me just mention one thing which
Roger didn't, which is our dependence in part
on Chinese dollar holdings and our need for
them to participate in the -- our lifestyle,
essentially, sustaining our deficit and our
debt. How much does that constrain us, if
we were -- if we wanted to suddenly side with
Japan and we suddenly saw the set of the -- the
head of the Chinese central bank suddenly
announce that they were going to cease dollar
purchases until such a time as the United
States backed off and reconsidered its deployment
of forces, where would that put us?
GREEN: They can hurt us. They can hurt us.
HAASS: I meant Treasury purchases, but you
know.
GREEN: They can hurt us, but if you continue
down that escalation or up that escalation
logic, a global economic meltdown is bad for
us. It's terminal for the Chinese Communist
Party. And obviously, we want to avoid that,
but we shouldn't be more afraid of this than
necessary.
And Abe spends 80 percent of his time on the
economy. And I imagine that for Xi Jinping
it's a comparable amount of his time. Abe's
told people this. I imagine for Xi Jinping
it's comparable.
So it's not like either leader -- well, I
think Jeff put it well. They have -- there's
a utility in a certain amount of friction.
Abe would not have come back politically without
China's pressure on Japan. But these economic
factors, I think, are very heavy in both leaders'
minds.
And we, for our part (OFF-MIKE) we're not
checkmated. I don't think this fundamentally
changes our toolkit in how we would deal with
a crisis like this.
EIKENBERRY: I guess I'd make two points here,
the first on the degree of interdependency,
not only between the United States and China,
but between China and Japan and China -- and
many other countries. It's pretty striking.
Last year's bilateral trade, over $500 billion
between the United States and China, the Chinese
hold $1.2 trillion of Treasury notes. They're
our largest source of imports. They're – China
is our third-largest source of -- or destination
for our exports. In the case of Japan, their
largest bilateral trading partner is China.
So I've heard people now talk about, do you
remember during the Cold War days that we
had mutually assured destruction with nuclear
weapons? Now people talk about mutually assured
economic destruction. And that's the world
that we live in.
I would -- I would take a little bit of note,
though, on the points you had made about our
economic relations with China. Actually, there
are -- maybe two years ago, I would have agreed.
I don't think that I would, though. The currency
problems that were really first on the agenda,
those seem to be managed now in a pretty good
way. The Chinese are very interested in a
bilateral investment treaty with the United
States, and now they've come forward in agreement,
they'll have a negative list, rather than
the positive, which we couldn't have moved
forward with.
And interestingly, on TPP (inaudible) agree
with you. Two years ago, you heard from the
Chinese, TPP is part of containment. Now,
increasingly, you're hearing the Chinese economists,
political leaders say if we can get a BIT,
then maybe TPP is next, because it could very
well be in China's interest, because if you
look at their reform package that they've
announced with the third of the 18th, then
the TPP could also be a very good model for
them to follow for the enactment of reforms.
HAASS: I apologize for the use of acronyms.
That's -- BIT is a bilateral investment treaty.
TPP is the trade agreement that's being negotiated
across the Pacific. And I will try to get
these people here to desist from the...
(UNKNOWN): We're from Washington.
HAASS: ... ADIZs and other such things, but
clearly, I'm failing in my -- in my efforts.
(CROSSTALK)
HAASS: There was somebody here. Yes, sir,
John?
QUESTION: Thanks. John Makin, Cornwall Capital
and American Enterprise Institute. Listening
to you gentlemen makes me wonder if the island
dispute isn't a red herring. That is, given
the range of issues you've discussed, let's
say we could -- we solve the problem tomorrow
and both China and Japan say we don't care
about this pile of rocks -- not likely, but
it's a good thought experiment -- in my view,
we'd still have some serious problems. And
as I think it's been pointed out, the Chinese
leadership probably hasn't planned on how
aggressive Mr. Abe is being, and yet Mr. Abe
is where he is because he's being aggressive.
What role -- and you've touched on some of
this, but is there a role that the United
States can play or can hope to play, or should
we just assume that we'll -- that there will
be a conflict of some sort and do a lot more
contingency planning?
GREEN: Well, we should do contingency planning,
because there are probably 20,000 people in
Washington who depend on that for their livelihood.
No, because...
(LAUGHTER)
Because...
HAASS: Is this a jobs program?
GREEN: As I said earlier, we need to be thinking
ahead about this jointly with the Japanese
so that we can urge restraint and do it from
a position where they'll be confident. The
-- the Chinese made Abe. He was in the wilderness.
He was finished politically, most people think.
He came back because the Chinese were beating
up the government in power. Without China,
there would have been no recovery for Mr.
Abe.
But I would say it's important to briefly,
very briefly define what he's doing. And people
talk about it as being aggressive. And the
shrine visit certainly didn't help with management
of that issue for him.
But if you set that aside for a moment and
just look at his actual policies, he's increasing
the defense budget by about 0.8 percent this
year after 11 years of decline. The Chinese
defense budget has been double-digit for almost
two decades. He said -- not that he's going
to revise the constitution -- that will take
time, he knows it -- he's going to change
some of the interpretations to allow a more
collective defense with the U.S., so that
we can have the kind of virtual joint and
combined relationships and plan together and
do more together that we do with Korea or
Australia or Canada or any number of allies.
He's actually slowed down that process, to
the frustration of many in the Pentagon.
So it's important to keep it in perspective.
He's not, you know, looking out for demons
to slay. He's spending, as I said, 80 percent
of his economy on what keeps him in power
in a parliamentary system, which is growing
the economy, and in that, not so unlike Xi
Jinping.
HAASS: Yes, ma'am?
QUESTION: My name is Contessa Bourbon from
the New York Times. How possible it is that
the United Nations can settle the territorial
dispute? Has the Philippines filed a case
against China at the U.N.? And is it possible
that conflict between Japan and China can
also be settled through the United Nations?
HAASS: (OFF-MIKE) about the Philippine case
(OFF-MIKE)
EIKENBERRY: Whether, you know, broadly...
HAASS: Whether that's a precedent in any way.
EIKENBERRY: ... whether these territorial
disputes can be solved by the United Nations
arbitration.
BADER: Look, you know, I think that the Philippines
-- you know, the Philippines did not consult
us before they went to the U.N. Law of the
Sea tribunal. And I think it's a good thing
they didn't consult us. I think the U.S. would
have discouraged them from going there, and
I think it's a very good thing that they went
there. I think it was very smart.
They have good lawyers, and they've come up
with a very good set of arguments, which focus
on the issue of the nine-dash line in the
South China Sea. And for those of you who
are not familiar with it, basically, that's
a line that the Chinese inherited for the
Kuomintang government, which covers 3.5 million
square kilometers in the South Pacific and
in which the Chinese assert some sort of unspecified
claims perhaps to all of the waters. It's
not clear.
Anyway, the Philippine case is challenging
that. My guess is the Philippines will not
do too badly in the outcome of the case. It
won't be an unambiguous outcome, but they
may do fairly well in it. And the Chinese
will ignore the outcome.
But I think it will help spur a debate within
China. There are a lot of lawyers in China,
there a lot of people who are looking at these
kinds of issues, and I think it will help
the people who within China take international
law seriously, who take globalization seriously,
and it will provide an argument, not for immediate,
you know, surrender to the Philippine position.
Now, this doesn't really go to the sovereignty
issues. I cannot picture a situation where
the parties go to U.N. tribunals on sovereignty
issues. Look, I mean, the Japanese have offered
to go to the world court on the Takeshima-Dokdo
issue, and the South Koreans have refused.
South Koreans would almost certainly win in
the case where they go, but they refuse, even
though they'd win. I mean, there's -- the
nationalism trumps the logic and the immediate
advantage in most of these cases.
EIKENBERRY: And possession, also -- also has
something to do it, as the Koreans have got
possession.
BADER: Yeah, that's right.
EIKENBERRY: So they don't want to take it
into arbitration.
GREEN: If there's -- if there's a diplomatic
process that could help, aside from confidence-building,
which Karl and I have discussed, between the
militaries, it's all about fish. And Japan
and Korea were at odds over Dokdo or Takeshima,
but in '98, they signed a fisheries agreement,
and the issue subsided until the fisheries
agreement started falling apart. And it was
local fishermen in Japan that started raising
this issue.
Taiwan just reached an agreement with Japan.
Taiwan also claims the Diaoyutai-Senkakus.
That fisheries agreement has calmed down a
lot of Taiwanese fishermen who were trying
to agitate and cause trouble. So if there's
an area for diplomacy that would make a difference,
in addition to military-to-military confidence-building,
it might be fish.
The stocks are moving north because of climate
change, so it's the fishes' fault. If we can
find a way to harvest them together more peacefully,
that -- that actually in the past has gone
-- in the recent past, with Japan and Taiwan,
a long way towards lowering the temperature
on these issues.
HAASS: I've been to a lot of Council meetings.
I've never heard anybody blame a dispute on
the fish before, and just -- at some point,
someone will speak up for the fish.
Jeff, you get the last question.
QUESTION: Jeff Laurenti. I wonder if you might
tell us, what is the view in Tokyo, in Beijing,
if any, of the American now phase-out, perhaps
fade to black in Afghanistan? That is, is
this seen as a sign of either lost American
credibility? Is it a sign simply that the
Americans have done their best and this is
a hopeless situation, a little bit of sympathy?
And particularly for the Chinese, who actually
have a border, small, but a border with Afghanistan,
and that have in the Uighur parts of Xinjiang,
major problems with jihadism, what is the
stake for the Chinese in a post kind of American
presence in Afghanistan in trying to keep
the Taliban out? What is their likely role?
One assumes the Japanese have no interest
or stake at all there.
EIKENBERRY: Well, maybe I can talk from Beijing's
view.
(UNKNOWN): Know something about Afghanistan?
EIKENBERRY: The -- I think what the Chinese
worry -- the only thing they worry about more
than Americans having a long-term presence
in Afghanistan is the Americans not having
a long-term presence in Afghanistan, because
as the uncertainty now is out there for all
of us to be concerned about, about what's
going to happen to our military relationship
and our security agreements with Afghanistan.
After 2014, will we even have one? The Chinese
are increasingly concerned.
And why would they be concerned? You already
mentioned one, the possibility, then, of Al
Qaida and their confederates. Specifically,
they worry about the Uzbekistan independent
movement gaining sanctuary, again, inside
of Afghanistan. They're worried, also, I think,
geopolitically about if they see the return
of a great -- new great game actors, but the
return of the great game, that they should
-- they would have great problems on their
western flank, and that could extend into
Central Asia, where they've made extraordinary
investments in terms of resource development,
natural gas, and oil, pipeline development,
and they also worry about the potential impact
on instability in Pakistan.
So we are talking to the Chinese about Afghanistan.
We talk about bilateral cooperation programs,
where I think the bigger opportunity is -- and
the imperative is, I think the Chinese understand
this, is that even if the United States of
America and Beijing were to sit down and say
that the two of us together and alone were
going to solve this problem, it's beyond our
reach, because there's a lot of other actors
who get votes, Pakistan, India, Iran, Russia,
and -- and the European Union, NATO can help.
Each one of those actors that are out there,
we probably -- we, the Chinese and the Americans,
have got comparative advantages in influence
and leverage that we have, so can we sit behind
closed doors and come up with a collaborative
strategy, but knowing that it's not going
to be bilaterally implemented, and see if,
as Xi Jinping and our -- and President Obama
have talked about, a new kind of relationship
going forward? It seems to me that's the kind
of relationship we should be working for,
that we don't want to minimize problems over
Senkaku and Diaoyu. We certainly want to work
to avoid a crisis catching us by surprise.
But there might be some greater global opportunities
for collaboration and alignment. I think Afghanistan's
one of them.
HAASS: And on that...
GREEN: Just on -- oh, sorry.
HAASS: Go ahead. No, go ahead.
GREEN: Real quick on Japan. The Japanese at
our request invested very heavily in stability
and development in Afghanistan, second largest
after us, in terms of ODA. And so I'm sure
they're frustrated and disappointed, as we
are.
But the event in that part of the world that
has struck at the Japanese and Korean confidence
in the U.S. was not Afghanistan. It was Syria.
And it wasn't that they wanted us to use force,
necessarily, but the fact that we -- that
the president said we would use force and
then threw it to the Congress, to the Koreans
looking at North Korea with chemical weapons,
by the way, and the Japanese looking at China,
that was unnerving. And that is what you hear
about when you talk to senior people in those
capitals.
BADER: Just...
HAASS: Sure. Yeah, the last one.
BADER: The U.S. dialogue with China on Pakistan,
which I have observed for years, is incredibly
sterile. The Chinese do not wish to have a
serious dialogue on Pakistan. They wish to
own the Pakistan relationship, and they don't
want us to have any visibility on it.
I think that Afghanistan is a bit of an offshoot
of that in a sense. I think Karl is right,
that we do in theory have more in common there,
and we should be able to do more, but I fear
that the Chinese approach to Afghanistan is
somewhat reflective of their approach on Pakistan,
which, of course, they use as a hedge against
India.
HAASS: I don't know how to say be careful
what you wish for in Mandarin, but anyone
who wants to own the Pakistan relationship,
I say, be careful what you wish for.
(LAUGHTER)
This is interesting. A little bit more sanguine
than I thought, and I hope you're right. I'm
not persuaded you are. But, again, I want
to thank you actually for two things. I want
to thank you for tonight, but amongst these
three gentlemen, we have literally decades
of service to our government and our country,
so I want to thank them for that, as well.
(APPLAUSE)